avec lionel larrère spécialistes du
numérique et cofondateur du site
ok donc point fr bonjour
ils gagnent maël l'arrière merci d'être
avec nous ce soir assure rt france alors
on vient de voir cette information d'où
vient cette agressivité de la part de
l'australie envers les mastodontes du
numérique elles sont à google et
facebook alors l'agressivité vient sans
doute d'europe puisque l'année dernière
l'union européenne a pris 1 une
directive qui est sensiblement similaire
qui va dans la même direction c'est la
directive qui a fait beaucoup couler
beaucoup d'encre si je puis m'exprimer
ainsi sur les droits d'auteur il a été
transposée en france l'été dernier
et donc elle impose aux éditeurs yves
aux géants du numérique de s'entendre
sur le partage des gains qui sont faits
grâce à la publicité sur internet
publicité qui est générée en partie
grâce à tous les liens qui sont sur les
plateformes sociales et voilà quand on
consulte les médias aujourd'hui on les
consulte d'abord via facebook via google
et les états disent on n'a plus envie de
payer pour la presse et ce sont aux
gaffes à de payer si vous voulez à notre
place pour subventionner la presse les
médias australiens disent souffrir de
cette concurrence de google et de et de
facebook l'état australien dit même que
l'avenir un de ces médias sont sont en
jeu est ce que vous vous connaissez
l'état d'aider
des médias en australie l'état des
médias en australie c'est le même qu'en
france c'est le même que dans beaucoup
de détails aux etats-unis c'est la même
chose il ya que quelques médias qui s'en
sort parce qu'ils ont compris internet
ils se sont complètement repensé et ils
ont fait des médias de plus en plus
qualitatif avec un contenu plus fort que
les gens sont prêts à payer aujourd'hui
sur internet on est un peu sur la course
au clic dans tous les pays et donc les
médias sont archi dépendant de base de
thé le google de facebook et cherche
d'abord à faire les clics
je pense que ce type de législation va
renforcer encore plus la dominance de
ses plateformes puisque finalement elles
vont chercher à faire encore plus
d'audience sur ces plateformes facebook
google plutôt que d'essayer d'avoir leur
propre audience puisque aujourd'hui
quand les gens consultent que
l'information
ils vont plus sur les médias mais ils
vont d'abord sur ses plate forme globale
et donc on va les renforcer encore plus
et on va sans doute aller vers une
information d'encore moins bonne qualité
donc je suis pas sûr que ce soit le
gourvenement google se disait déçu par
cette décision australienne est ce
qu'aujourd'hui google ou facebook
pourrait éventuellement faire quelque
chose en australie justement pour
protester contre sa décision
alors il ya déjà des choses qui l'ont
fait en europe donc on peut imaginer
qu'ils font la même chose en australie
et notamment de j'espère que vous avez
fait l'expérience mais quand on partage
un certain nombre de sites de presse en
france sur facebook ces derniers
n'apparaissent plus avec un aperçu on ne
voit plus la photo et ça c'est parce que
les les éditeurs et facebook en
l'occurrence ne se sont pas entendus sur
la redistribution des gains et donc
facebook a dit bah je vais appliquer la
loi strictement et donc si je dois
donner de l'argent pour faire apparaître
une image sur sur les fils d'actualités
sur les fils d'actualités de
2 mai internautes et ben du coup je vais
je vais jouer le jeu jusqu'au bout et je
vais voilà je vais appliquer la loi et
je vais payer personne et du coup ça
fait aussi moins de visiteurs pour les
plateformes
donc on est sur un jeu où de toute façon
les gars façon un petit peu en position
dominante
parce que c'est eux qui ont toute
l'audience est ce que cette décision
australienne pour pourquoi pas devenir
un exemple pour d'autres pays qui se
battent justement contre ces mastodontes
du web
moi je les dis en tout début en fait
c'est quelque chose qui vient d'abord
d'europe
donc c'est plutôt l'australie qui imite
l'europe alors peut-être de manière un
peu plus agressive de manière un peu
plus fort notamment dans l'expression là
on voit bien qu'ils ont décidé de jouer
un bras de fer mais on a eu à peu près
les mêmes polémiques à 1 en un peu plus
d'un an en europe
donc je pense que c'est un mouvement
général est on est on en est qu'au début
merci beaucoup il y en a l'air d'avoir
été avec nous ce soir sur arte france
rappelle avec vous êtes spécialiste du
numérique et cofondateur du site
ok d'appoint fr merci beaucoup